i'm a big fan of this show
super happy to talk to you guys um so uh
one of the things about the first season
is that it had an overarching
storyline with bitsy trying to acquire
the park
and season two feels like it's a little
bit more freewheeling that it's not as
you know that that it's not some big
story line if you will
um can you sort of talk about season two
maybe what's different about it
we realized that the serialized uh shows
are very fun and very
difficult in a fun way but then i think
with season two is more just like well
let's like
give the characters just a little room
to like spread out and just have a story
that's
diving into coal in a store that's
diving into mali and
give them a little space and maybe not
be you know keep an arch
because that's that's who an ark because
that's who bitsy is and that's what she
wants but like
maybe a little more room for everybody
to
kind of tell their own stories a little
more yeah and telescope
back in time if we need to you know
really
take a moment to yeah to stop the clock
not not a race like nora said not not
get rid of the ark but just
take a take us a moment in time and
explore how we got there who's you know
who's
whose uh backstory needs to be expanded
a little in order to appreciate the
moment
yeah i thought you did season two what
i've seen i saw the eight episodes that
were provided i thought they were great
uh and i don't want to get too specific
but uh i loved episode eight
and the way you guys worked in like lego
and all these movie references i don't
want to spoil anything uh
but that can you sort of talk about
mixing in some pop culture if you will
into
the show we have dabbled in that area on
bob's burgers and it's really fun
because we
are i guess everyone in the world is a
movie buff so it
is easy um and it's also kind of like an
easy structure
where like the audience gets what you're
going for and then you can
play with jokes within that structure so
it makes the
joke writing kind of easier it makes
like
sort of the drama that you're going for
with your character's internal conflict
easier
it's just very helpful frankly and also
it's just kind of a fun way to whip
through
several stories for each character i
always like it too because it's
characters telling stories to each other
so you're in the voice you're a writer
but now you're
making your character a writer of this
particular tale
and i find that to be um really
charming it sort of you know brings you
back to when you're a kid and you
you are playing with your legos telling
telling stories to whoever
um and then i think in this case we were
just talking about this but uh
in this case you also right in the
middle of the the silliness you have
this beautiful song in in molly's story
which is you know which was so heartfelt
so i that that was nice that that was
the the central park
version of of that kind of storytelling
um that felt really
i think um yes you could have suddenly
the thing could feel you know deep not
just
um rapid fire movie references but all
of a sudden
also a real character moment uh trying
to make any show is difficult
animation makes it hard i mean the level
of difficulty that you guys are trying
to do with this show is
is it's really hard and then you're
adding songs
which is like okay let's just what what
day have you thought about let's just
take songs out f this i can't do it
anymore
i mean every day or another way to say
it is
you the songs are so wonderful but
it kill speaking for myself and nora in
particular it kills us
if the eyeballs aren't right in the
breakfast scene
too you know what i mean so we we
live in unfortunately i think the curse
is
you know you just always want to get
nailed uh nail the
acting nail the animation nail
everything
um and it becomes uh very difficult
because you
you may say oh we you know we pour all
our resources into the song that's what
we're doing you know we're doing a
musical but you can't live with yourself
if
if a a take is off or
the eye line is off in in just an
in-between scene that's not a song
that's just a joke or a little passing
moment
um so you know it's sort of uh it's a
curse because you
you gotta you know you end up staying up
late trying to get those right or you
inspire other people to stay up late and
get those things right
hopefully now that the show is
successful and people know about it
hey is it are you sort of aiming at any
singer songwriters that you really want
to bring on the show
and can you sort of talk about because
you've had such great songwriters
already
um i love the songs i'm just curious
what you're thinking about for the
future
i have one man that i've always wanted
to get on but
i mean it's rain it's i'm a giant randy
newman fan
i mean like pre pixar at pixar but pre
like everything he's done so i mean
that's my dream person
he's an amazing like storytelling
songwriter
i don't know i don't know if that
answers your question but that's what
all i'm thinking right now
that's the question yeah i mean you
can't it can if you don't put it out
there
it you know what i mean you gotta randy
watching this yeah exactly
um before i run into time with you guys
i am curious though about the bob
burgers
bob's burgers movie um what's the status
of that
it's coming working working uh
hard on it uh excited to bring it out
into the world
excited also to bring it out at the
right time uh we're not
you know we do not want to be the first
movie back in theaters at all i mean i
know we're not
already we're not the first but we don't
we're not in a hurry to be in
in theaters until it's really uh
come back uh people are going to the
movies and feel
safe and you know comfortable there and
we have to finish it
so we're you know it's not um
you know it's not next month uh we don't
have a date yet we'll announce very soon
um but we are we're hard at work on it
up late at night i don't know if you can
tell
um but uh hard at work
uh will it resolve where uh this the
show takes place
oh the nameless seaside town is that
what you mean we've actually
said it in the episode it's just been it
just went by quickly
it was a blink and you miss it and now
i'm not going to say it now because
now it feels like a thing i'll leave it
be i'm just going to say seriously
congrats with central park i love the
show
i'm super happy to help you promote it
thank you thank you appreciate it thank
you thanks steve have a great day